Today
it's,
I'm trying to overcome American
dominance in the world,
are trying to overcome the American
military,
um,
bullying that's taking place here and
there in the world in Iraq and
Afghanistan and,
you know,
military bases in 100 countries.
And I think people are trying to work
their way towards a more democratic
society wherever possible
and to do it without war.
And,
and I think this movement towards a more
democratic society,
society is more concerned with human
rights.
Oh,
we've already seen it begin to happen in
Latin America with movements from
autocratic and elitist states to more
populous states.
And it may be that the European Union
represents this in some way.
And,
uh,
it's a longterm process.
But I think,
you know,
what is going on is an attempt to create
a world which is different than the
world of the past hundred years,
which was a world of an incessant war
and domination of the world by
superpowers.
First two superpowers.
And now one superpower.